SPEAKER 1: That is all stated
to be in the interest of us
being ruled by our reason.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
What is the longest surviving
written constitution
in human history?
AUDIENCE: The Magna Carta?
SPEAKER 1: Students
are wonderful.
AUDIENCE: I was going to
say the Ten Commandments.
SPEAKER 1: Are
those constitutions?
AUDIENCE: I don't know.
It's an agreement between
God and the Hebrews.
SPEAKER 1: Is it?
AUDIENCE: Worth a shot.
SPEAKER 1: I don't
think they are the 10
contractual provisions.
[LAUGHTER]
No, the Magna Carta is
an element of the British
Constitution, it's true.
But the British Constitution
doesn't come to be with that.
It takes more.
Oh, come on, you guys got to be
able to answer that question.
AUDIENCE: The
American Constitution.
SPEAKER 1: Ha.
Ha.
We have now named the
elephant in the room.
This constitution is the
longest surviving thing
of its kind in all
of human history.
And I think we've
reached why right here.
Step 1, it gives effect to
consent to representation.
Step 2, it locates all the
sovereignty in the people,
not in the government.
No one in the government
can say that he or she is
acting of his own will, right?
Step 3, it excludes
the sovereign
from the ordinary operation of
the government, which places
a check on the sovereign too.
And that is all stated to
be in the interest of us
being ruled by our reason
through discussion.
James Madison was aware
that reason and speech
are the same thing.
We should talk things
through before we do them.
And it should not
be our passions.
Passions don't tend
to last that long.
Convictions do.
Reason does.
And you're arguing about it
all the time all along the way.
And that means that Madison says
that these arrangements here,
this connection between the
people and the government
that gives power
to the government,
locates ultimate
authority in the people,
prescribes how the people
must hold opinions over time
to make them effective--
this is a set of arrangements.
What does this make it
possible for them to do?
They can delegate the authority
to more than one place.
You can give the legislative
power to the Congress
in Article I of
the Constitution.
You can give the executive power
to the president in Article
II of the Constitution.
They each have their
own relationship
with the sovereign people.
They are quite equal
as regards authority.
You can give all
the judicial power
in Article III to
the courts, and you
can use Article I and Article
II institutions to combine
to appoint the judges.
You can leave most of the power
in the hands of the states,
and you can protect that in
Article IV of the Constitution.
You see the symmetry and
the strength of that--
all made possible by this
consent and representation.
If the sovereign was
in the government,
whatever part of
the government--
and Madison writes this over
and over in the Federalist,
Hamilton too--
whatever part of the government
the sovereign was in,
that would become
the dominant part.
Whereas now, we can
separate the powers and then
they can be stronger, which
you need, but still also safe.
So what that means, then, is
that the principle of human
equality under the laws of
nature and of nature's God
gives rise-- and all
this happens, by the way,
in about eight lines in the
Declaration of Independence--
gives rise to the principle
of government by consent.
We hold these truths
to be self-evident,
all men are created equal
and endowed by their creator
with certain inalienable rights,
among these life, liberty,
and the pursuit of happiness.
To secure these
rights, governments
are instituted among men,
deriving their just powers
from the consent
of the governed.
That follows from
equality up above--
under the authority
of the natural law,
which is just our perception of
what kind of thing each of us
is, right?
We're not like dogs.
We're also,
interestingly enough,
not like god or the
angels, who aren't
mentioned in the Declaration
of Independence, right?
And so once you've got
that, then all of a sudden,
you lay the ground
for a government that
is grounded in the
people, but the powers
are so arranged so that the
better angels of our nature,
to quote Lincoln,
drive the government.
And that, the claim by the
founders and the claim by me,
they believe, the founders
believed, that this government,
because it's in accord
with human nature, which
is that nature above the beast
and below God, this government
can last a long time--
in principle, as long as the
Earth lasts or people last.
And it has lasted a long time.
SPEAKER 2: Thank
you for watching.
We hope you're enjoying
our Highlights series
and invite you to explore
all of Hillsdale College's
online courses.
They are free and for
everyone who loves to learn.